well I was going to say something but I
have nothing interesting to say so I'm
just kidding working the scenery because
that's what i need to do i really need
to get this being done somehow i also
look it might just be me though but i
also i always just want to have some
land around my rides and not have rides
next to the border with a plaque I don't
know why I just did like doing that and
it seems like there's a bit of a border
over here as well yeah I'm gonna add a
bit of land I've got the money anyway so
why not okay so get get rid of all those
straight borders though this border is
not that great either and hopefully I'll
actually get some good research because
currently i'm getting that information
thingy but that's not really something
that i need or once but if i get a nice
flat ride i might be able to place over
here and then have a path go there in
some way I suppose I'll figure something
out but at least it kind of fill up this
area because they see as you can see
this area is kind of empty right now and
the problem that I have with this is the
coaster is very far away from the rest
of the park it's really it's it's got
its own kind of land over there and
that's not really something I like so
I'm just gonna buy this land already
because I find the money I sir howard
corrupts and money is power this is
capitalism so he's gonna buy that land
and people are actually enjoying this
wide 07 16 per hour it's not that much
but it's good and the color scheme
should be changed though especially when
it comes to the cars I might just keep
the track like this but the car is is
still terrible so I see suppose a run
like that will work and uh road yeah
that seems okay hold on hold on is that
that what kind of a name is that that's
not the right color that's not the right
shade of that's better yeah
okay so this is the superest and upper
loop de loop which was supposed to have
OMG at the end but that didn't work
because rob lv and that sucks but i can
buy this land though this is lan are you
kidding me are you [ __ ] kidding me
are you [ __ ] kidding me damn it chris
sawyer what the [ __ ] I am I am so
disappointed you were my childhood hero
but this one thing over here just know
why why I can't expert I can't expand my
Park now I don't want to expand and just
just build stuff all over here and just
have that one one little tile over there
with I can't even bite oh my god wow man
you don't goofed it's not that hard to
add pieces of land where you combine the
land mate as oh why did [ __ ] sake why
is this thing called what is slide ahhh
why don't have a better name for its own
i'm looking at Babbo but it's still
troubled name um so yeah what kind of
scenery did I want I could play sir this
sexy are sexy [ __ ] but I don't
know if I really have space for Lance
and that is kind of the issue here I
mean there's plenty of space but it's
all very hilly and terraformed and
that is not good I'm just gonna build a
wall over here because of the box and
give nothing to build someone as well
and little curve in there because you do
need you do need some curves of course
mm-hmm seriously though when is my voice
going to stop voice cracking here when
it does that and I some reason you're
ashamed of that even though you really
can't help it like how can you prevent
your voice from voice cracking I don't
think there's a real way other than yeah
I get enough sleep at him I'm in the
middle of the test week how do you
expect me to get enough sleep okay hmm
hey can I uh no no I'm not get that not
gonna do that just get a place palm
trees we deserve nice yeah and I know
that I always rent about these things
not being realistic and it's true these
things are not realistic as in don't
build forests out of palm trees don't
place random palm trees everywhere they
require loads of maintenance and you
really can't place palm trees everywhere
that's impossible I'm just gonna do it
because it looks cool so I'm sorry
you realistic fans out there I'm going
to play some palm trees hmm hold up wait
I might use these things I mean the
cabbage tree does it really look like a
coverage to me but it's a cool looking
tree so might as well and yeah I'm just
going to place that thing so now we've
got some decent area in terms of foliage
however that's one cabbage tree too many
that's one palm tree to bless and brunch
robbery because you do need that even if
you're not going for realism there is
never enough Graham trouble I know this
is an old joke land p boys used to make
rip all the forum's ever but that
doesn't matter you know stereotypes
exist for a reason and this thing
definitely needs more grunt robbery e
that might work
I suppose that's good and a bit more
over there because i am still afraid of
the emptiness I don't want to leave any
bare spots of course this is this is an
exception because I kind of planned on
building another flat right over there
or a gentle ride rather and now that I
do have that information think I'm
you're gonna build it and this is not
really close to the entrance but it's
close to the only part that you can
actually are well access the other part
of the park so that makes sense and the
water slide is up and running again and
at some point it's of course gonna fail
again oh wait I remember now that is the
problem with this thing but it like
breaks down and the lift Hill doesn't
work the boat just get stuck because it
can't go on the lift Hill or manages I
goes back and then you get that terrible
stuff I think that's the issue oh I
might MIT I might be wrong about this
but I think that's it something along
the lines of that but anyway the point
is those things are annoying and they
always break that right so I is really
anything else so connect to this area
except that i need to add some ventures
through this and they it to something
over there and i'm just gonna add some
small foliage you can do that I think
that's good and there's some stuff over
here as well
does it kind of spice it up yeah even
though it makes no sense it looks for
and that's what we're going for right so
what else do we have this thing is still
wait the price I was a terrible mistake
I can actually make more than twice as
much money as i was making on this thing
that's the only problem with this it's
uh the higher the intensity rating the
higher the excitement rating also is but
then again there's a certain point and I
think that it's actually at eight where
the higher your exact intensity rating
goes the lower your excitement rating is
and that's why the excitement rating in
this thing isn't all that good even
though it's got a Twitty but prettier
twisty and loop-de-loop the track
because that's the name of the coaster
of course this sir Christian name is
definitely not lying it is definitely a
it definitely stands up and it's got a
loop-de-loop if it's super I don't think
so it's a tote what it is super of
course funny when it wasn't super we are
are we getting anything else yet I the
bumper come on that's just a one flat
ride that I absolutely despise why and
now that I've got plenty of monies I'm
just gonna my hand man handyman's anyway
okay um
okay we got bumper cars anyway let's
forget about the hand man and get bumper
cars this is the problem this so big the
the building of course not the bumper
cars those things are way too small but
about that no don't okay thank you no
idea how I'm going to fit an entrance
and an exit in this face I'm gonna
figure something out okay I've got two
more months or left to actually reach my
goal of getting how many 650 guests in
my Park with a rating of at least 600
that's gonna be hard my rating is
definitely way too long i still need to
extract many more guests e oh well I'm
gonna go see what I can do hopefully I
can figure it out somehow and we're
gonna go just something makes sense I
makes no sense come on I'm just gonna
well
we bucket on
well
ok back to the bumper cars how do I even
know and a cute line over here without
making it look too weird because this is
a quite annoying little hill if I say so
I suppose that works no that works I
mean it's stupid what else can I do and
this is going to be the exit and then
it's all fine so that's one of the worst
bumper cars have ever built but then
again it's bumper cars who gives a [ __ ]
ok and little path and a little come on
cue it's a cue that's the worst q I've
ever seen I'm just gonna open it that's
the bumper cars beautiful now we already
get that beautiful bumper cars music and
I turn that off well I suppose I can't
where's the is the music turn off
section play music oh actually oh hold
on hold up I did not realize I kind of
forgot that you can change all of that
so we're gonna play some nice music nice
music that I want when you go oh did I
uh no it's in this section right over
here my music yes now we're gonna take
that out then where was it again the
Egyptian yes oh my god the park is ten
times better now okay so we're gonna
interact many more guests and get much
more profit now because we have
excellent music and this area needs more
of these things
very nice and I think that's it yeah
anything that I really need is a small
fence over here and then i'll call it a
day okay so i'm just gonna play some
small stuff around this little thing
like that kind of spice it up a bit and
some ground shrubs and that's about it
for this ride however i'm just gonna buy
a bit more land so i can actually play
some stuff on it there we go actually I
want to I don't know why I just what I
have trees okay nice think I'm not that
actually did make the entire area look a
lot better than it did before I'm happy
about that and I think the park is
pretty much finished if I really look at
it I didn't even think I've got space
left I don't know if I've got a mana
mana rules not really something that I
can do anything with and it's not I
don't know why I'm just a big fan of the
small gentle flat rides and of course
the other flat rides as well I'm not a
racist and but you know you just run out
of the normal flat white and then you
get all of those things like monorails
and these car rides that nobody likes
get them out of here but yeah you can't
do that these games stupid sometimes
seriously if you really want to build a
really big park you kind of need more
flat whites than you currently have in
the game or at least in many scenarios
but that's just a small issue and then
again I do like the research system
though don't get me wrong but sometimes
i'm just at the end of the scenario you
were kind of running out of things and
even though you've got a maximum at
maximum bingi you just got stuff that
you don't want like this meat there's
railroad kind of thing and these challo
so what are you even supposed to do with
those things I mean I know that
transport things but they're not really
efficient at that and they're not really
fishing and making money in their
annoying to build and they ugly but such
as my opinion but I just don't like them
and guess what
things just got stuck again I think it's
just broke no it's not even broken ah
god damn it just just get those things
out of there Oh nope it's not able to do
that so it was broken after all wasn't
it and I was working again I'm such an
idiot I just removed the entire q for
what for nothing okay that was a stupid
move what was filling up again though so
I probably didn't lose too much money
but I I don't know why I didn't say
there was broken like here it says
broken down by the way that are way too
many rides are broken and you can i buy
more mechanics by McCann as if you buy
people and just you know okay add more
honeymoon as much as I despise desert
levels the nice thing is that is that
you don't have any grass so you don't
need to assign those handyman to not mow
the grass because that's good annoying
and let's get these little things
because it's not enough Bush action
going on here
if you're not with us you're against us
the monorail yay finally got it i'm not
gonna build it nope it's a shame you can
already see the next thing that's also
good I suppose but it's come to check
and it got stuck again one hurry up is
that is it actually moving or what like
why is it stuck once again just gonna
close it opening again what the slides
are the worst things I mean at least
it's not fiasco for us but it's still I
like the look of them though I like them
in real life some are going to complain
too much money but their reliability I
wonder what the reliability of this
thing is actually like where did I see
that again so like how do I keep losing
everything huh Wow where is it its
popularity oh my this terrible oh wait
there we go the eighty-three percent
yeah yeah likely story and damn Nicki
Minaj is not reliable at all wow she's
got making ten thousand euros an hour
though so that's really good and this is
the part where I'm actually earning a
lot of money and I don't have a negative
company value so that's cool so yeah I
do like the park there's loads of big
rise going on though that's one thing I
notice we don't really have a general
gentle right area just roller coasters
everywhere that's kind of like a six
flags except it does kind of have
scenery not much but it has scenery it's
not right rides placed on parking lots I
suppose that's a difference
slight but important difference now the
only thing that I really have left is
the air rides another F right and this
roller coaster which is also equally
tough so I think everything else have
built away you can build all of these
things already yeah I still don't know
why this is an an intensive and add
thrill ride but whatever and how is it
how is a cinema a thrill ride was that
even and go chords on all that thrilling
either well whatever I would argue that
a opponent house can be more thrilling
than a sum of these three lights quote
unquote thrill rides but then again it
all just depends it's todo stand-up is
doing very well I mean our 840 customers
an hour that's eight hundred and forty
people torturing in an hour and actually
paying money for it and I'm earning
money huh that's a great scenario so I
wanted to expand over here but that's
just not going to work so in the only
area of really lack got left is this
area but i don't think i can buy too
much like I can book I can barely buy
anything over there I'm like plenty over
here though but this is not really an
area why I think I should expand
and again I might try it and downwards
with all the puke over here Billy's of
what to slide that table did not see
that one coming also good i seriously
just unmotivated grass if there's no
grass in this entire park wow that's
right now if there's any more vandalism
you can barely see it on the benches if
people are sitting on it because some
some reason people still sit on benches
while they are actually broken but
suppose that's not too much of an issue
and we know how much money this thing is
making oh I can actually raise the prize
huh I wonder why that is I can't raise
the price of these things actually can
wait this one is 160 and it's aha 360
come on make it a 360 this thing is they
are he's making everybody for me so it
should at least be expensive and that's
it I don't know what else I'm getting
just a gentle ride I know that already
these are all the roller coasters that I
got hold on i forgot the corkscrew
roller coaster do I have enough time
left to do two are just one month hmm
don't think that's quite enough to
actually build something and if I would
try it it would be pretty hard I see a
bench over there that's I've analyzed so
do want to repair that I think there's
anything Paris we always broken down
think I'm just gonna try and finish the
scenario right now but I don't know how
mmm one of this wings still making money
and how reliable it is it's still more
reliable than nicki minaj Wow I'm just
gonna build a UH Monaco's over here and
then that didn't work you know I could
go for a very standard to cook so I'm
just gonna try it I'm gonna try it okay
how long you I've left one month okay um
save save that [ __ ] save save game yes
yes save and okay you have ultra turbo
mission built the roller coaster okay
have the path over there and I'm guy I'm
gonna buy land over here tons of land oh
wait this is probably already going to
be more expensive than I can actually
afford whatever just try it don't have
any money no money i'm just gonna build
it anyway suppose that when we had I'm
gonna try hard and anything is possible
if you really want to do it okay so this
seems like about you know planned I
barely have any money left for a roller
coaster however this thing is says it
costs 3900 upwards and I already have
that so it can't possibly be more
expensive right okay so it work over
there no definitely not let's go mobile
station and go up
and that does not work oh oh I know do
some interesting stuff with that like go
down and do that but that looks shitty
hmm got space rings I've got space rings
I've got space rings ah but those things
are awesome but I need to finish this
ride okay so we're gonna make this
yellow because every every
self-respecting no wait yeah I don't
know that's actually good idea maybe
orange that's the standard color after
all just gonna try orange I don't know
what they did with the supports over
here great not too sure if I like that I
might just copy that I mean that is very
cheap now i'm just gonna make them black
and unlike right okay however this
doesn't work so abort she's gonna make
the station shorter I don't know there's
actually going to work out but try it no
that won't work out okay just a little
bit more short and supposed to this
might work yes it does okay so we've got
that going on
I think it's too low it's too low well
damn it and that case i'm just gonna
build it like that how did that are the
bushes over there and she's gonna remove
it anyway because it kind of looks
awkward and small curve and then we're
gonna get 10 I'm gonna go down here and
do that and do that I suppose that works
out and I think this thing's got half
corkscrews it's only got corkscrews I
don't even have a looping so you can't
work with that so I'm just gonna try it
like this see if i can get a curve or
something in here buy more land because
i need more a bit more
possibly still more yeah i'm just gonna
buy more land dude i have money and I
don't have a lot of money left whatever
I have money okay so we're gonna turn
around here and then doesn't work out
hmm i suppose that sir that is actually
pretty cool but that doesn't work out no
no way so not going to do that I'm just
gonna see if there's anything else I can
do helixes are too expensive and what's
the day 18 oh I don't have a lot of time
lapse this is a terrible idea um what
should I do hmm
oh I can't do that yeah I can do that oh
yes I'm doing this I am doing this oh I
don't have the number no no it's the end
of the month give it give me money give
me money oh my god no give me money
please it's the end of the month just
this one this one roller coaster please
oh god oh god no how much are only ten
I'm not gonna make that I won't be able
to make enough money I won't well there
goes that goes my dream this was my
dream roller coaster this is the moment
that I'm in trying to achieve my entire
life just can it couldn't and the only
thing I've really done in the last month
is just wreck my company value that's
probably a lot lower now yeah it's only
13,000 now a good [ __ ] job but at
least I bought almost all of the land i
could buy so i suppose that's cool this
is all room for future expansion
[ __ ] and the only reason i did I
don't want to buy this little strip of
land is because this sometimes this game
is really stupid you know what if I mine
useless strips of Lana mise well by all
of the land like this he's gonna buy
this land to see this my park is huge oh
yes look at all that land I got anywhere
else they can buy some land over here so
I'm just gonna buy this line too
beautiful and I'm just gonna buy this
too because I can because all this land
i own i mean my coaster filled but i can
always buy some more land I don't know
why it just I don't want this piece to
be the only piece when I bought too much
land and of course it's the UH how much
time do I have left Oh three days that's
plenty of time to buy more land
okay not enough cash Oh hold up wait
give me this one thing okay thank you
okay that is actually nice that is
actually nice I don't know why but it
makes more sense for some reason if you
still have some room left so it's not
that crime um okay so how many days do I
have left and apart the company value is
now a lot lower but I don't care it's
sir the park is better I suppose now
hold on hold on it's not a desert
without cacti give me the let me just
place the extra cacti what's the date
31st okay just a couple of cacti just
let me place this oh my god no let me
let me make this nice suit okay thank
you um the name is um silver at yes okay
gorgeous we turn over the lightkeeper
sorry um okay I cleared it I click the
scenario time to save yes we're moving
on to a new scenario hell yes okay um
new game we are gonna don't freeze come
on we're gonna play leafy lake yes but
that's gonna be next time so see you
then